[Music]
from Apple TV plus what are we looking
for again
that's agario
there's only 600 of them left in the
whole world
you know chimpanzees can't swim based on
the mission of Jane Goodall the animals
are in danger every year there are less
and less of them we have to help them if
everyone worked together we could save
them
only if we understand what we care only
if we care will we help Jane Goodall
said that I know
you recited every morning
let's go imagining let's see pictures
something you've never thought of before
like save some beats ready graveyard
[Music]
for play into action ready if you are
cute and then ugly kind of way
s imagine a better world and journey to
save one species at a time
we're trying to feel like they'd like to
come out at night sounds like quite the
mystery have fun saving the world
together huh together
foreign
on Apple TV Plus
[Music]